bonjour c'est pierre manuel barré pour
brut action alors le premier moment qui
a changé ma vie
eh ben je crois que c'est je crois que
c'est quand j'ai eu un enfant un peu
comme tout le monde on sait que ça
change la vie ça bouleverse l'existence
on dit que c'est on dit que c'est
beaucoup de plaisir on dit que c'est
beaucoup de bonheur
moi je trouve que c'est surtout
difficile à cacher à sa femme et puis
franchement le franchement l'air de
l'enfant tant qu'il est dans le ventre
de sa maman c'est celle attendre c'est
fait c'est quand il sort c'est tellement
déceptif un enfant sait faire que deux
choses du bruit et du cac à 1 comme un
petit sénateurs mais tout nu après
l'enfant après l'enfant si tout se passe
bien
iguerande il atteint sa taille adulte y
travaille pendant 40 ans et il meurt
d'un cancer
car honnêtement à choisir je préfère
prendre un écran plat et en plus bon
entre le en soit les jouets les couches
les lessives les pédiatres la maternité
et les déplacements à l'école les
vacances à la montagne ça un bilan
carbone dramatiques que ce soit celui de
la couche d'ozone celui de la sécu ou
celui des femmes
un enfant ça ne sait faire qu'une chose
à grandir des trous alors le deuxième
moment qui a changé ma vie je m'en
souviendrai toujours c'est quand j'ai eu
mon premier césar pour mon rôle de
pakistanais qui fait une gpa avec le
petit fils de christian clavier dans
qu'est ce qu'on a fait aux mondiaux
cette le moment qui a vraiment changé ma
vie c'était y'a pas longtemps
c'est quand j'ai calculé mais point pour
l'assurance retraite la bonne nouvelle
c'est que j'ai trouvé un simulateur de
retraite très bien foutu qui
t'expliquent euros tu vas te faire
[ __ ] et la mauvaise nouvelle c'est
que tu vas te faire [ __ ]